let me let me let me pull up this story
that this is from uh daily mail gop rep
madison cawthorne claimed he carried
weapons in his wheelchair on january 6
to arm those around him in unearthed
clip of a phone call now hold on there a
minute
the first thing i want to say
the left is using this
uh to to insinuate that madison
cawthorne was trying to arm rioters
that's not true madison catherine was
talking about arming members of congress
and their staff to use opens against the
rioters here's the best part though
unearthed clip so saith daily mail
what does that mean
this was on a public broadcast it was on
it was on the charlie charlie kirk's
podcast i believe this wasn't unearthed
anybody who watches that show and it's a
very popular show knows this was said
they're saying on earth because they
don't view you as a human being and
citizen of this country you don't matter
your conversations don't matter they
unearthed it i love that analogy
christopher columbus did he discover
america no
well first of all he landed in the
bahamas but if you want to talk about
discovering the continent there were
already people here from a european
historical perspective that's that's it
right that's how i view this these
people are like look what we've
discovered and it's like bro i saw that
episode like that was a long time ago is
this news to you
i didn't actually see the episode that's
the point though they say this
catherine was interviewed by phone on
conservative activist charlie kirk's
radio show on january 6 seemingly while
rioters were actively storming the
capital the freshman lawmaker said
everyone around me is armed but didn't
say where he also claimed rep lauren
bobert was carrying a weapon that day
the colorado republicans previously told
fox news just days after the
insurrection that she had not been armed
that day but said others were well then
maybe madison catherine was incorrect
because a direct source contradicts it
neither cothor nor bobert have responded
to a request for comment
so if um an insurrection is happening
against sitting members of congress in
the government and one of them is armed
and says quick the writers are coming
take this weapon shouldn't the democrats
be happy about that
shouldn't they be like wow he was
actually threatening lethal force
against violent insurrectionists he's
stopping the insurrection he was
fighting back that's right right madison
cloth weren't tried to save this country
from the insurrection that's the
headline right there insurrection where
basically nobody brought any weapons
right that insurrection
well some people brought weapons not to
the capital but you know they had
weapons in their cars and stuff like
that but
the craziest thing about this is there
was a reddit post i saw where they're
they're they're pushing this idea
that kawthor and bobert were arming or
mostly cawthorne was arming rioters
like they were giving they're claiming
that a man in a wheelchair was about to
commit like a lethal terrorist attack i
mean it's he's in a wheelchair i mean
who's going to be afraid of him yeah i
don't know this is another story where
you can see they lie
they manipulate the truth to make it
seem like it's odd because the daily
mail is conservative but it's also
english so we're kind of coming this is
an odd story for that reason and it's
it's literally it's a complete
misrepresentation of what happened
it is a competition complete
misrepresentation what happened on earth
and also yeah carried his weapons in
wheelchair to arm those around him are
you leaving a little bit of important
context out of that one
yeah a little bit i'm just going to say
too that i can't believe how deeply
entrenched their ideology is because for
them to look at something like someone
actually bringing a weapon where it
might need to be used and scream and
point and freak out that's silly to me
like he was possibly potentially
defending some of these people but they
have to control the narrative so that it
looks like he was trying to arm the
rioters when in fact we know that a huge
majority of the people there did not
even have arms at all which
flatly contradicts their ongoing
narrative that they were there to cause
trouble and due violence to the people
who were at work there is this is this
show uh this is a charlie kirk show is
was this is is it the same as his
podcast do you guys know or no i think
so not sure this was uh charlie kirk's
investigative reporting of having a
public conversation yes i'm sorry yeah
i'm on earth
on the radio
but no i mean think about that when so
to these people in in in the media
because look i know it's i know it's
daily mail is is is conservative and
they do often challenge they're kind of
you know they can go either way it's a
big company um
the the reason they say that is because
the the the reddit threads and the in
the comments about it were like newly
discovered clip
these people in in establishment and
corporate press
they think you you watching a show it
doesn't exist
they have to discover it and then say it
was discovered
but it's kind of like bro if if
if there's millions of people already in
america and then you show up i tell you
but you didn't discover it there's
people here well it it makes me wonder
luke as someone who does genuine
investigative journalism and asks to
interview people and comb through
information and find original sources
when you see that people can watch a
podcast clip a moment from that podcast
and then call it journalism how does
that make you feel
uh you know i think there's a couple
issues here the first is kind of
ascribing malice when you know
incompetence is an easier explanation
there's a lot of journalists now that
aren't really even journalists they're
lazy low-paid 22 year olds who don't
know anything about anything and they
just literally like look at reddit and
write a little blog post
you know but the other thing is when i
was doing the loud and county story and
i revealed this cover-up of a rape the
other media didn't cover it and by doing
that they relegated it to this
conservative media story and so i think
that sometimes it works to their
advantage the story becomes stigmatized
just because they didn't cover it and
then they you know it's it's circular
reasoning they cause it to be a
conservative media story and then they
say well we don't need to go into the
conservative ghetto and read things
because if it's a real story it'll come
from us
conservative ghetto it's a good way to
put it yeah we need parallel economies
you know it's there was a point where i
said i'm worried about it with the
censorship and and everything that it
was going to force people into two
separate economies now it's time
the the the the anti-establishment it's
not even just conservative but the
anti-establishment post-liberal
libertarian conservative whatever group
need they need their own infrastructure
we need our own payment processors which
there there are some we need to
basically tell these people we just
don't care anymore you know it's not
that we don't care it's that it's
pointless trying to talk to people who
don't view you as a part of civilization
or society when they when they when they
actually act as though you are like some
kind of
you know
peasant or uh subterranean humanoid
creature who's not on par with them and
their nobility what's the point in
having a conversation with that person
they they consider your outlets fake
news
if i'm going to write a story
and then they say it's unearthed or they
call it you know conservative news says
that's just like i don't care who
they're talking to those people are are
you know
they're not paying attention they're not
interested in paying attention
so so we got to find people who are
actively looking for answers and want to
improve themselves you know
you can lead a horse to water but you
can't make them drink as they say
so i don't know
maybe we do want to try and wake a lot
of these people up but for the most part
i look at this and i'm just like
they they view you as an unhuman you
can't make them drink you can make them
thirsty but that arguably thursday run
them around a lot salt then when you
take them in the water they're more
likely but that's with a human that's a
little unethical to use using like a
horse you know so i don't know if making
people thirsty well it's okay you can
reason with a person i mean attempt to
dude reason it people are seeking logic
and reason they need it it's part of the
balance of the spirit and i think it's
missing so maybe you can bring reason to
people that might help i mean truth be
told you can definitely make a horse
drink i kind of understand the saying
it's like you can bring the horse to
water and then you can
splash a bucket in his face
you can jam a you know it hose in its
face or something and spray it and it'll
it'll get mad but you know
it depends on how many people you have
you could you could tie the thing down
and pour water and it's a horse abuse
well like if you've got a horse that's
dehydrated yeah it needs to be probably
inner uh what do you call it
subcutaneous fluids yeah a little
injection under the skin
horse iv drip yeah yeah
you know what i when i see stories like
this
and it's just another day another same
story i just wonder you know what's
what's the next step in the in the
escalation and the polarization and the
splitting because now they're actually
trying to insinuate that a sitting
member of congress is arming rioters for
an insurrection
this is just completely consistent with
their narrative and this is something
that they've refused to let go of which
is really interesting to me to watch
because even in the midst of ukraine and
all their posturing and politically
correct virtue signaling about how much
they dislike russia they still have time
to point out that oh january 6 was still
truly terrible never mind that ukraine
is actually being shelled by russians
this is still the worst thing that's
ever happened on american soil just a
bunch of old people who wandered into
the capital building
november is going to be lit it's already
been lit this year yeah that's crazy for
us yeah
well one thing i want to mention here
about the media and media bias i'm sure
you guys can probably relate to this on
some level unless your evolution
occurred more quickly than mine but even
just a few years ago i understood and
viewed the media as being left-wing and
having that bias but i still thought
i can see what they're saying and every
once in a while they might get something
right but at this point my perspective
is that they are always lying all the
time and i can literally trust nothing
that they say and to sort of segue into
your investigative reporting when you
look at the loudoun county case with
them referring to a father who was angry
over his daughter literally being raped
in a cover-up in the media reporting on
this is if he was some kind of maniac
and the face of
parental abuse of teachers
yeah and i mean what i did with that
story was so simple that everyone saw
the story on cnn the video every news
outlet uh of this guy being arrested
this kind of overweight white male
plumber that got beat up by the cops and
handcuffed at a school board meeting and
they all thought they knew why they
didn't need to ask him why he was mad
because they all thought they knew he
was a bigot he probably hates gays he
probably hates blacks who knows but we
know um and so all i did is call him up
and say look
your video is being played around the
globe we all saw that you were mad why
were you mad and he told me that his
daughter was raped three three weeks
prior by a boy wearing a skirt and the
superintendent had just lied and said it
never happened so uh
it is uh you know baffling and they're
they're it's not as if the investigative
resources aren't there i mean they
literally were
went out of their way to obtain video of
this guy and put him on tv but no one
thought to to call him yeah i mean
that's that's really a horrific part of
this scandal is you literally called the
guy and that's how you got this
information i think the absolute minimum
that these journalists should have been
doing let me let me read for you a quote
from george orwell sheamus
you know what really frustrates me about
the orwell quote stuff though is
whenever you do it they pull up his
fictional writing and i'm like no no
tell me about the man in his
recollections of history and
observations so this is one of his
greater quotes
he said early in life i had noticed that
no event is ever correctly reported in a
newspaper but in spain for the first
time i saw newspaper reports which did
not bear any relation to the facts not
even the relationship which which is
implied in an ordinary lie i saw great
battles reported where there had been no
fighting and complete silence where
hundreds of men had been killed i saw
troops who had fought bravely denounced
as cowards and traitors and others who
had never seen a shot fired hailed as as
the heroes of imaginary victories and i
saw newspapers in london retailing these
lies and eager intellectuals building
emotional superstructures over events
that had never happened i saw in fact
history being written not in terms of
what happened but what ought to have
happened according to various party
lines how little things change amazing
how little things change shame it says
spot on because
i look at this and i'm like that's
exactly what we're seeing now
it's amazing has it ever really changed
has it always been that way i think it's
always been like i think so but what's
really fantastic is the fact that at
least for the time being the average
person does have the ability to look
into things on their own so alternative
alternative media didn't really exist at
that time in the way that it does today
we are able to broadcast our messages to
literal thousands if not millions of
people
well and i came across a meme the other
day was talking about if the news is
fake imagine what history is like and
i'm like that's really interesting
because we all know history is written
by the victors but who knows what their
take on it was who knows who knows which
part of the victors is actually
recording what happened thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there